Welcome back to our big birthday bash.
(sirens wail)
(audience claps)
Well, you know what that sound is.
It's giveaway time.
More birthday gifts for the birthday gang,
and first up, my FLOWER Beauty Petal Pout Lip Scrub
and Lip Mask in the shade, Berry More.
(audience claps)
I scrub and mask
with this all the time.
I'm giving this away
with total confidence that it's gonna make you guys happy,
and that's so important to me to have your back.
You'll never go to the bathroom and go,
"Oh, my lipstick."
Not on my watch.
(audience laughs)
And where is Jessica Cantu by the way?
Right here.
(Drew gasps)
Surprise!
(audience laughs)
Hello.
We heard that you have been on a weight loss journey.
Yes, Drew. I am.
I've been working two jobs for about three years now
and so I saved up money.
I took out a small loan, emptied my savings account,
and I paid to have my gastric sleeve surgery in May 2021,
and I've lost 115 pounds since then.
(audience claps)
(audience cheers)
Well, you're an inspiration,
and to keep up with the momentum and add to your routine,
we have the new Hydrow Rower Exercise Machine
plus a year-long access membership,
and the package is-
That's amazing.
Valued at over $2,500.
(audience clapping)
And this is all the rage in exercise right now,
'cause it's such a full-body workout.
(upbeat music)